the Democrats versus Santa a Yuletide
impeachment now the final act of the
House Democrats impeachment push will
roll out in the next few weeks Democrats
have a very odd Advent in store for the
American people their hope is to hand
the president a gift-wrapped impeachment
in time for Christmas for weeks
Americans have suffered through the
Intelligence Committee chairman Adams
shifts mind-numbing hearings where
witnesses claimed that the President did
and did not engage in a quid pro quo
where and when he withheld military aid
to Ukraine no one on this planet told
you that President Trump was tying aid
to investigations yes or no yes no one
told me directly that the aid was tied
to anything
I was presuming it was do you ever talk
to President Trump in 2019 no I have not
you were not on the call I was not on
the call and the first time you actually
read the transcript of the call was when
it was released to the public that's
correct
mm-hmm what shifts committee failed to
do is unearth any convincing evidence
that the president should be impeached
polls supporting impeachment are
actually slipping which we'll get to
later in the show with some incredible
pollsters as Democrats swing in swing
districts sweat out this impeachment
push concerned about the political
penalty they could pay next year the
spotlight moves from shift to the
Judiciary Committee which announced
hearings next week now
this is the time of year when people all
over the world look forward to the
appearance of a Rollie pollie man
carrying a sack of goodies on his back
somehow I don't think this is who they
have in mind
if we get the evidence if we have very
convincing evidence and convincing
hearings and people understand what's at
stake I don't think that there will be
negative political consequences for
protecting the Constitution isn't he
cheery filled with Christmas cheer
Jerrold Nadler is chairman of the
Judiciary Committee the Congressional
source or a congressional source tells
me that this is the man that Pelosi
initially removed from the impeachment
inquiry because he's so bungled the
Malheur hearing remember that flop
Judiciary Committee will come to order
I do not intend to summarize or describe
the results of our work in a different
way I will not comment on the actions of
the Attorney General or of Congress
after that tragic showing Pelosi just
wasn't confident in Avalons ability to
make the case but the Judiciary
Committee must draft the articles of
impeachment so it now falls to Nadler to
convince Americans that there are
grounds to impeach the president despite
the fact that Schiff got nothing
programming note next week's hearings in
judiciary will involve constitutional
scholars musing on what the founders
meant by high crimes and misdemeanors
that should be gripping television let's
consider the cultural timeline for a
moment step away from the politics at
the height of the Christmas holidays are
Americans really going to be focused on
Nadler or Santa I took to the streets
for answers this Christmas season will
you be focused on impeachment or Santa
Claus in the holiday Santa Claus in the
holidays absolutely Santa Claus Santa
I'm gonna say Santa don't judge me
Santa Claus and getting rid of the
Democrats impeachment absolutely
impeachment why because it's important
you won't be focused on impeachment will
not impeachment is a waste of the time
it's a waste of time yeah so you're
gonna be jingle Belling all the way I
think I'll go to 34th Street see if
there's a miracle there out of the 40 or
so people we interviewed a grand total
of two and you saw them said they would
be focused on impeachment now the
holidays aside Democrats have a
political high bar to leap over here
they face an energized president who is
forcefully pushing back as he did last
night in Florida scam it's a hoax
everybody said that's really but
Americans have so much to be thankful
for the economy is booming wages are
rising crime is falling poverty is
plummeting
confidences sorry and America is
stronger than ever
before the economic news is pretty
incredible
jobless claims last week fell by 15,000
unexpectedly
and new government statistics out today
showed that the US economy grew faster
than expected in the third quarter they
revised growth upward to 2.1 percent
it's going to be awfully hard to impeach
a president most Ignite kind of record
with scant evidence hearsay and an
election season around the corner
Democrats may want to get in line at
Macy's with that lady right now a
Christmas miracle may be the only thing
that could save their prospects in the
new year